Ragdolls (yo yo its ya boyy)
Hilarious!
I can't stop laughing
Look at him
Go!
*Laughing*
Hahahahaahhahahahahahaha
(Laughter)
(Demonic Laugh)
Today we're playing "Human Fall Flat"
Today we're playing Human Fall Flat
Today we're playing human fall flat
So in this game, you can customize what you want to do
Annnddd uhhhhh
Your character
You can customize your character guys!
(Intense Orgasm)
Uhhhh Uhhhhhhhhuuhhhh Uhhhhh UH HUHHH
*Evil laugh*
"Facial recognition got a hit
"Jesus Christ, that's Jason Bourne!"
(weird laugh)
Yes, I'm 12
Ahaha-ha!
How do I take the fucking picture?!
*Pewds Laughing*
mmmmmmhmmmmmhmhmhmhmhmhmhmhmhmhhhh
*Deep inhaling*
(*mouth noises*)
pshhspshssshhhhh
Jesus Christ, that's terrifying, dude!
Oh my God, alright, apply that shit man
Alright we haven't even played the game yet
So let's do that now
Ow
(KIM KARDASHIAN QUOTE:) "they ask you how you are, and you just have to say you’re fine when you’re not really fine,
but you just can’t get into it, because they would never understand"
I walk like I shit my pants
Which is how I walk anyway
(Sad music, Katy Perry quote)
Well, I'm going to kill myself.
(Katy Perry quote in background quietly)
Oh.. I'm stuck!
This is like a metaphor for YouTube
Oh! That's how I get up in the morning.
Well then
Let's uhh
Let's go in here man
Ah fuck, this is a metashit man
Let's press this one
"They will press every button-" Yea yea yea
Alright, I'm ahead of you already
Fuck off
I think I have to push this away, right?
There you go
Yea fucking piece of shit!
Fuck you!
Ass
hole
Alright now we gonna
AAAAH (Die Ragdoll Pewds)
This is why everyone clicked on the video to watch me solve puzzles
This game is surprisingly lackluster
Where the hell am I?!
Ugghhh
"Mission failed! We'll get him next time."
(Rock You Like a Hurricane plays)
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Got 'em!
Yeeeaaaaa
God! I look depressed
This really is a YouTube simulator
Dude, this is easy
This game is too easy for a brilliant mind
like..
I
am
I'm so... What the fuck are you doing?!
OKAY
Can I get
some epic music?
(Pokemon anthem)
Can I get some serious epic music?
Thank you
Now I'm gonna make this jump
Gonna take some extra speed
Wipes off his sweat
And he goes..
Nailed it
*Roar* "Way to go!"
Ah shit
Ahhhh shh
Ahhh
I've  done it now *Depressing music plays in background*
Oh God, box.
"Don't let me go Pewds"
No..
Box
No
My videos are painful enough already
I'm not gonna play any more puzzles
Don't worry I got more games
Let's go
Alright, let's start with 10 meters
Saladass
Come on Saladass
Yes *Metal Gear Solid Alert*
There is it
GO! Saladass
Go
Saladass
He's got a great form
Look at him
He's just... SHIT!
Now that takes talent
And he finishes off
By
Humping the air
Bubababa Bah! Bubah!
He's flying
He doesn't need to run, he needs to fly
*Success music (Chariots of Fire Theme)*
Go saladass
I need some serious music
*Back to the Future Theme* Now, this is all  on him.
Saladass' life depends on this
He's been gambling in the wrong ,wrong neighborhoods
What the Fuck are you doing Saladass?!
Saladass, you fucking ass
Come
Saladass wants to run so much but
God does not let him run
Aw shit Saladass!
(Katy Perry quote)
What the fuck is that Saladass?
Oh, now he's trying a new technique this year apparently
(music plays and intensifies)
My name is Saladass
and I am the fastest man alive
Oh my God
I think
Saladass
just
fuckin' snorted
OH NO
SALADASS
NO
GET UP GET UP
GET UPPP
I don't know what he's do
Oh he's back up
SALADASS!
COME ON
COme
WHOOO
SALADASS!
SALAD who?
SALAD
That's right
That's salad
You always bet on the Salad
Always bet on the salad
That's what my mom said
Salad always bet on Salad
So that was Ragdoll Runners
That's a cool game man!
Ragdoll games! So fun!
Am I right ? (No)
What did I tell you at the beginning?
I need boobs in my thumbnail
Surely, there's a game about boobs and ragdoll
Come on, come on.
Papa, papa needs a new Lambo. Come on.
Come on.
This is a calculator boob necklace
That's funny
That's a boobs coloring book
That's hilarious
There's a boob ice luge
That hilarious
Oh, you can drink from it
Hey, wanna look like a piece of shit?
We got cha covered man
Now we're talkin
alright
Uhh, what's my location?
OK we're gonna have to
Ahh add like a fake location
I'm in Gothenburg
Okay, that worked
OHHHHHH
WOW
It's a game about
boobs
after silicon
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Who lives in a pineapple under the sea???
What do we want?
Mama's got a new package
Oh
from that angle
There's always that weird gap isn't it?
(Katy Perry quote)
I think we have to end that episode there
(repeats)
Rag doll boob pyshics
(From pinned video:) I'm a call from Clauswhich
I'm a mastermind military strategist
Filthy Nazi ner-
g- g - Norwegians
Marina: This is uhh-- just spent um, the past umm...
Im Rick Harrison
And This is my pawn shop
I work here
With my old man
And my son.
AND.
In 23 years...
I've learned one thing.
You never know what.
Is gonna come through that door.
Dicks out for harambe.
"Bulbasaur!"
(The Flash intro plays)
MY TRIGGER WORD IS KIDNAP!
"They ask you how you are, you just have to say you are fine, when you're not really fine.
but you just can't get into it because they would never understand."